salut les ventes à l'eau aujourd'hui je
suis pas tout seul et n'ont t'ils la vie
il ya quelqu'un est peut-être moi c'est
monsieur clément bompoil messi anecdote
marrante dans la vidéo que j'avais faite
sur pie celle ci sur la deuxième je
parlais d'un mec qui s'appelle clément
bompoil qu'avait un record sur lequel il
avait récité trait le plus rapidement
possible 300 des six nations
ce sont des 6600 décimales de pi claude
déjà je te casse en est mort
et alors le truc marrant c'est que en
parallèle de la sortie de cette vidéo
clément il m'a contactée sur facebook
mais il savait pas que je parlerai de
lui et que c'était déjà prévu et moi je
savais pas qu'il allait me contacter et
web bref si tu as réussi à faire ça
c'est aussi parce que tu as une capacité
était un peu un x-men x-men d'un livre 2
août c'est faux bond inattendu
synesthète sa naissance il est et je
vous avais parlé une fois très
rapidement de la synesthésie en disant
qu'ils allaient 152 forme de synesthésie
en tout cas de détecter aujourd'hui et
bien c'est un synesthète et c'est à dire
que concrètement c'est quoi la
synesthésie synesthésie c'est qu'on va
mélanger différents sens fin que ça va
se faire automatiquement les semences
pour se mélanger
par exemple lors des chiffres en
couleurs des choses comme ça et du coude
à plusieurs formes notamment de la
synesthésie pour moi la synesthésie au
niveau des couleurs c'est ouais 7 voir
la vie en rose
ça permet de rire jaune de pas voir des
idées noires et d'éviter les pages
blanches
je pense que je vais d'après cette
phrase non mais tu avais écrit inter
comme ça sur toi qui étais super bien
d'ailleurs je mets le lien de facebook
de clément bompoil directement dans la
description si vous voulez voir
j'avais bien aimé ce texte là en fait
c'est hyper intéressant parce que toi tu
fait spontanément sans aucune maîtrise
d'ailleurs de se faire connaître des
choses que nous on essaye de
rationaliser quand je vous parle de
mémoire et de vous faire des images de
mettre des couleurs et c'est d'associer
deux sens tu vois c'est du connexion qui
a directement dans ta tête
c'est ça qui sont pas maîtrisés du coup
règles et c'est dingue
est ce que est ce que du coup ça se
traduit aussi par des émotions est ce
qu'il ya des choses que tu aime ou pas
et des choses qui sont pourtant une
matériel ou pas concrète genre des
chiites des tonneaux mena il ya des
choses immatérielles fin était celui je
vois par exemple nombreux 36 des fois
qu'il va être stressant c'est pas pour
ça s'est levé jeudi normalement du monde
46 ça me stresse intégrable à un moment
donné est un freeware niveau des jours
par exemple dans le relais mardi va être
vert au moins le mercredi orange de
choses comme ça
échec par exemple tous les mardis de
l'année 2001 tchèque le mardi 9 janvier
2001 le 20 février où le 25 septembre
c'est savoir un goût de menthe
aftereight alors pourquoi parce que j'en
ai mangé je pense qu'une fois que j'ai
pas aimé un jour de cette année à
s'associer au mardi parce que sévère et
que j'ai ce goût là en fait en douce
conjuguant quand j'y pense et le verre
c'est des trucs que tu aimes pas du coup
le vert c'est plus associant général des
trucs que j'aime pas il connaît même pas
trop le marny quoi on n'aime pas trop le
mardi tous les genres le 30 6 octobre
ont pu savoir la salvetat imaginions
fait on fait des efforts de
mnémotechnique pour vraiment exploité
par infos-chalon surtout c'est d'avoir
des techniques mais toi on est toujours
impressionné par ce n'est pas à moi j'ai
hyper impressionné par toi
excusez moi on va se pécho avant la fin
mais je m'approche de lui pour sa 36e et
away et tout à l'heure on parlait parce
qu'il écrit des textes aussi tu écris
des chansons de famille des choses sur
youtube qui sont vachement cool je vous
mettrai ça aussi on parler de la manière
dont tu avais d'écrire des rimes
c'est ça et ça je trouve que ça traduit
exactement ce qui se passe dans ta tête
des fois il va pas faire rimer comme
nous on l'entend deux mois entre il va
aller faire rimer au niveau de la
couleur que celle de renvoi en fait
mentalement ça c'est ça qui m'expliquait
que ça il ya des mots qui vont que je
vais écrire et qui vont sûrement un peu
une couleur c'est une sensation est
directement et un autre mot qui va être
attaché à s'embêter qui va venir
et du coup il ya ce mot là je décompose
en plusieurs sens il ya une rime qui
n'aide à partir de sang fait incroyable
rinne qui est bien ou pas d'ailleurs
mais ça fait une rime ou c'est un truc
et je construis une histoire du coup
elle est est ce qu'on a une explication
scientifique de la synesthésie ou pas ça
alors il ya beaucoup de voir dessus
qu'on peut trouver plein de choses sur
internet sur ça et les facteurs
génétiques pourvoi qui rentre en compte
qu'il ya des facteurs des chocs à la
tête etc
jeudi dans une chanson j'ai été bercé
trop près du mur s'il faut jouer mais
sinon il ya pas mal d'explications qui
sont donnés ou non et apprécié là bas
c'est comme quand ce que tu fais pour
deviner ce qui se passe dans la tête des
gens passer ouais ouais mais moi je vois
le procès de dix
procédure quoi la méthode parce que lire
bien comment ça se fait et s'est
connecté comme ça non mais il ya encore
tellement de choses qu'on sait pas tenir
ses sacs et des fascines en quoi est-ce
que tu as hâte a créé des handicaps sur
certaines choses ou pas il ya des par
exemple chez closer mon numéro moins
important j'ai aucun numéro de téléphone
jaune à fin juin que le numéro on fait
du patron des rg que numéro est ce que
je vois qui ça correspond il forcément
effet numéro qu'on voudrait oublier deux
choses comme ça et ça répète cependant
avec un peu en disant ah oui tu as well
as un petit peu comme les les
hypermnésique parce que c'est une partie
qui a oublié dur à oublier et oui
puisque ça crée un souvenir c'est un
souvenir que l'émotion pour avoir
quelque chose façon ça va ça va pour ce
pour tout le monde bien sûr mais du coup
voilà avec la synesthésie s'est décuplée
quoi ça et je comprends après c'est
qu'il ya des exercices pour symboliser
l'oubli
j'avais besoin par exemple tu peux
écrire quelque chose que tu veux oublier
sur un papier et le brûler c'est un
geste symbolique mais ça aide à faire
travailler l'inconscient là dessus j'ai
une question quand même par rapport au
record que tu as eue par rapport à pis
donc pour bien préciser le record c'est
d'avoir dit des 600 premières décimales
de pi le plus rapidement possible c'est
à dire en trois minutes je domine
aujourd'hui deux minutes 08
ça me plaît à l'aise alors du coup
comment ça se passe c'est à dire tu as
est ce que tu décris quelque chose
mentalement ou est-ce que ça devient
comme ça afin de la confiance soit
inclure la conjuguant safer 1 459
dossier 5 3 5 87 9 3 2 et en fait c'est
ça fait un chemin gens jouent à un arbre
par exemple pour le 1 et ensuite ça
change c'est une super vite je veux voir
une sensation qui va arriver c'est que
sur les vingt dixième décima et la 20e
c'est que tout le monde ait droite des
fois tous impact est de faire ça je peux
pas expliquer pourquoi
par contre je peux pas les refaire à
l'écrit ouais donc en gros c'est j'ai
testé une fois en france auraient
d'ailleurs à l'écrire et jeu ça marche
pas il faut ça vite en fait je peux pas
les écrire lentement est-ce que tu as
mavs va pas faciliter l'accès et du coup
je
et au niveau de l'apprentissage ça s'est
passé comment sais tu les as lu
plusieurs fois et ce chez imprégné ou
l'imprégnation j'allais vraiment lu et
j'ai pas cherché à faire de nos débuts
en fait c'est ma venue à la base j'étais
en stage de fin d'études je dois qu'un
créneau en manager et l'horaire c'est
14h15 donc 1,4 1,5 et là j'ai des chefs
ni n92 machin je regarde d'où ça vient
je vais payer 16 heures ap quand même et
donc du coup non je me suis dit ok si la
première décimale et je voulais voir
jusqu'où ça peut aller du coup je crois
j'avais lu et ces machins et je pensais
en avoir entre 600 à 1000 à peu près
égaux face à 6 ans quand il a dû la vie
en bleu daniel chomette achemine un jour
bleu je suis un joueur de l'heure je
suis en train de lire est et à ce qu'ils
mangent du coup les walis mercredi en
bleu ouais merlus et pendant que lindon
qui est phénoménale force ou cassés on a
note daniel t met à nous ses clés - fois
comme elle sait le manier le thème est
vraiment de ces femmes ne sais pas ils
font ce sans fil et se sert aujourd'hui
fin on n'avait rien demandé un père et
là on s'est fait tacler l'on perd si
daniel tammet tu étais du top 14 pour
ton rugby serait de regarder tu vois
donc jamais rien dire japan et enfants
pour cette fois c'est bon petit bonus en
allait arrêter la vidéo et puis clément
et on fait alors on peut pas faire un
petit truc de mentalisme et/ou en fait
j'ai jamais fait de mensonges de vérité
de visualisation sur un synesthète donc
je ne sais pas du tout ce que ça va
rendre
j'aimerais alors je pas trop trop garde
est pour l'instant
j'aimerais que dans ta tête sans donner
deux signaux physiques que tu imagines
une pièce que tu mets ça dans ta main
droite soit dans ta main gauche soit
dans ta poche d'accord tu me dis quand
c'est fait bon d'accord c'est bon c'est
bon ok je vais te poser de question
prend toujours un temps de réponse parce
que si tu dis la vérité
il faut pas que ça devienne trop vite
parce que le mensonge y seraient écartés
ça peut donner un indice
donc tu comptes jusqu'à 1 dans ta tête
quoi qu'il arrive que tu dises un
mensonge et la vérité tu me dis ta
réponse samar d'accord première question
est ce que la pièce est dans tes mains
ok maintenant le petit truc en plus dont
je te parlais c'est un déplacement
mental et sur les synesthètes je sais
pas ce que ça va
si la pièce est dans ta main droite tu
va la mettre dans sa poche si elle était
dans ta poche tu la mets dans ta main
gauche
et si elle était dans ta main gauche tu
la laisses ici pour m'embrouiller te
laisses faire un déplacement mental si
besoin et où rien et tu le dis quand tu
es prêt c'est bon c'est bon ok
maintenant questions en rafale tu
réponds le plus vite possible soit la
vérité sur un mensonge c'est toi qui
décide quand est ce que la clé c'est de
l'entêtement
est ce que la pièce est dans sa
chaussure non est-ce que tu as bien
mangé ce matin
oui 37 ça te fait quoi comme émotion
c'est dans la suite peu bizarre ok
superman c'est 1 37
je suis non contre superman c'est le
lundi dimanche ont fait beaucoup plus
rouge as tu vois jusque-là pied c'est
dans ta main droite
oui ok je pense avoir eu les mains
gauches c'est correct mouille c'est au
coc et moi j'ai appris que superman
c'est un petit peu le lundi quand même
sérieuse à décoller du coup franchement
sur ce passage là il ya deux mecs chelou
en même temps la cia n'a pas qu'ils
mangent à le clou c'est franchement
france grand talent et en plus je me
suis dit il va se planter et pas du tout
ah ouais ça va ça fait cool merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo on
va couper là parce que ça doit être des
jeunes
un petit peu long merci à vous merci mon
pote c'était cool
rassurant pour le cinéma aussi l'espoir
qu'on doit garder le contact ensemble si
la vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez nous
faire savoir et soutenir la chaîne en
mettant un petit pouce en l'air
n'hésitez pas également à vous abonner
avant de partir puisque le mental bloc
cette vidéo par jour pendant un an du
1er janvier au 31 décembre donc rendez
vous demain à 17 heures ciao